higher which forces it out of his hand
mccollum gets free and fires and hits cj
mccollum
the advantage of having another guy so
you over play
damien lillard well cj where you at
finds him
and he gets a big shot tired again
jaylen brown
number of guys out there feeling it
right now brown's one of them
little double clutch and gets the soft
roll shooting over nurkic
he's played great all all game long
kemba walker as mark said
on the minutes restriction sitting this
one out down the stretch
brown by the way 13 of his points here
in the fourth
that's a side to side swipe and the
fallon ties his
fourth number 27 celtics third team foul
you think about it jalen brown will you
know you make the case be the third best
player with kimba healthy love his
attitude
well you see that in slow motion how
impressive was that
and having dealt with him on the world
cup team
he doesn't think he's the third best
he's got the confidence
of an elite player throws it back out
gary trent jr bang tran junior with
another big
bucket and portland goes up by one how
about the fine from damian lilly that's
a big time play
that's his 14th assist the season high
for lillard
they're they have now hit eight
three-pointers here in the fourth
quarter
hayward answers down the other end and
boston goes back up by one
what a game back and forth they go
throwing haymakers at each other
[Applause]
lillard to nurkic nurkic drives inside
flips it up misses it second effort no
good
rebound hayward a minute 20 remaining
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
trent jr now on jason tatum
tice and a foul on the entry pass bad
foul by mccullum you got to make them
make
shots to beat you a minute remaining
this feels like a playoff game lillard
from downtown
in and out that one rattles out of the
rim
if you're appalling you don't have to
foul and if you're the celtics
looks like they're going to run the same
action trying to get gordon hayward
against the smaller mccullum
lillard very aggressive defensively
trying to go for the steal tatum
dribbles away
kicks it out in the corner three-pointer
brown pucks it
celtic lead
[Applause]
marcus smart denying
lillard up top carmelo anthony for three
it's good
carmelo anthony makes it a three-point
game raisers to inbound
down by three they're out of timeouts
and brad stevens in a zone
[Applause]
finds lillard little of the dribble
throws it inside nurkich lays it up and
in
with three point four remaining guarding
the inbounds pass
portland has to be careful not to foul
beforehand paul goes in and mccollum
fouls right away
[Music]
mccollum fouling who else but gordon
hayward
now the question for brad stevens is
do you foul do you put a guy on the ball
gordon hayward at the line for the
celtics well there's nobody that the
celtics would rather have in this
situation
than gordon hayward with his clutch
free-throw shooting
and only eight tenths of a second went
off so three seconds to go so even if he
does hit these two
and they go up by three three seconds
you have time to throw it down the floor
catch even dribble and get off a quality
shot and if i'm boston i'm not putting a
guy on the ball i'm shading my big
entice towards lillitt
hits them both
throw down the court and he threw it out
of bounds the celtics will
inbound now underneath their own basket
didn't touch anybody how about gordon
hayward continuing
to be so clutch in the fourth quarter
from the line
so now the celtics to inbound
all portland can do is try and steal the
inbound get a five second or foul and
hope they miss free throws
and they're just in a i love this play
where they're moving before the ball's
in
they find tatum and tatum is fouled
2.2 remaining
[Applause]
now certainly a costly turnover by
nurkic
obviously clear what he wanted to do but
lillard started to come back the other
way and one
was unable to track it down he looks
like he took
lessons throwing the ball from dr fauci
that's just not necessary
that's their first miss here in the
fourth quarter from the line they were
nine for nine
that's not your first time disrespecting
the new york city point guard
regis high school absolutely
tatum seals it there that makes it a
four-point game
and the celtics are gonna hold on
survive
what a game